à kiev on retrouve à présent le
correspondant de france 24 gulliver cra
gulliver on scrute en l'imaginent avec
beaucoup d'intérêt peut être un peu
d'angoissé aussi ce qui se trouve dans
ses réponses américaine et la réaction
russe
oui bien sûr mais je pense que il n'ya
probablement rien de surprenant dans ses
réponses le ministre des affaires
étrangères ukrainien dmitro coup là bas
a dit dans un briefing ce matin qu' il
avait pris connaissance du contenu de ce
document qu'il avait été consulté que le
cren avait été à pleinement consulter
pendant ce processus et qu'il n'y avait
aucune objection à ce que les américains
avaient été créés dans le document
qu'ils ont soumis aux russes je pense
que le débat en ukraine ne tourne pas
vraiment autour de l'idée qu est-ce que
les américains offrirait aux russes dans
ce document mais plutôt autour de l'idée
jusque qu'elle quels sont les risques
que vladimir poutine est prêt à prendre
et puis aussi est ce que cette demande
que l'ukraine n'accèdent jamais à
l'automne et que cela soit est gravé
dans le marbre si vous voulez était
vraiment une demande réelle ou bien
juste un prétexte pour envahir l'ukraine
parce que le vrai cible de vladimir
poutine selon la pensée dominante en
ukraine serait non pas de dompter lauton
mais bien de reprendre le contrôle sur
l'ukraine ou bien à l inverse pour pour
le point de vue le plus optimiste est ce
que c'était juste il s'agissait de faire
une demande extravagante pour obtenir
quelque chose et que en réalité il y
aura eu quelque chose dans ses
négociations avec les américains qui
auront satisfait les les russes et il y
à toute la gamme de d'opinion qu'il y a
entre les deux mais encore les experts
en ukraine militaire s'accordent à dire
que une invasion avec des troupes qui
traverserait la frontière la russie même
si ces forces ont là s'ils sont nombreux
n'est pas prête à cela techniquement
pour le moment et puis certains idée
semble vraiment assez farfelu contre
regarde le terrain même s'il ya beaucoup
de forces russes en biélorussie et au
nord de la frontière ukrainienne le
terrain est marécageux là c'est des
forêts il n'y a pas des routes avec des
poncifs mon forte pour porter des tanks
alors les ukrainiens sont très
sceptiques quant à la possibilité par
exemple d'une invasion qui viendrait de
cette direction là en tout cas peut-être
une indication tout cas de l'hiver dans
ce cas dit aujourd'hui lors d'un point
presse le chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne pour lui et bien le nombre
de soldats russes déployées aux
frontières avec le crâne est insuffisant
pour une offensive à grande échelle
aujourd'hui
exactement ça c'est l'avis des analystes
militaires ukrainien et c'est aussi la
position articulé par les autorités
ukrainiennes qui sont aussi souci est
bien sûr d'éviter une vague de panique
au sein de la population
mais techniquement quand on regarde les
détails on pense j'ai l'impression que
leurs arguments sont assez bien fondé il
souligne tout de même que la russie
pourrait assez rapidement faire venir
les troupes et le matériel nécessaire
mais il est une question de plusieurs
jours pour faire cela et il y aussi la
question des jeux olympiques de pékin
beaucoup pensent que vladimir poutine ne
souhaiterait pas envahir l'ukraine ou
procéder à une quelconque escalade
majeure en ukraine pendant les jo de
pékin ce qui risquerait de susciter la
colère des chinois